escribe 514 como una fracción impropia
recordemos primero que es una fracción
impropia acuérdate que una fracción
impropia es aquella que tiene que el
valor absoluto de su numerador es mayor
o igual que el valor absoluto del
denominador
entonces queremos convertir este número
mixto en una fracción impropia tenemos 5
enteros un cuarto que es un número mixto
porque está formado de un número entero
y un número fraccional por eso se llama
número mixto tiene una parte entera y
una parte fraccional
ahora el método para convertir este
número mixto en una fracción impropia es
hacer lo siguiente 5 por 4 que es 20 más
1 y en el numerador ponemos eso 5 por 4
+ 1 que es 21 y en el denominador
ponemos el mismo denominador de la parte
fraccionaria que es 4 ese es el método
entonces cuando tenemos cualquier número
mixto y lo queremos pasar a una fracción
impropia lo que tenemos que hacer es en
el numerador de la fracción impropia
ponemos el número entero por el
denominador más el numerador y en el
denominador ponemos el mismo denominador
de la parte fraccionaria lo voy a
repetir para que quede claro en este
caso queremos convertir cinco enteros un
cuarto en fracción impropia esto se hace
de la siguiente manera en el numerador
vamos a poner
la parte entera por el denominador que
es 5 por 4 y le vamos a sumar el
numerador que es 1 y en el denominador
ponemos el mismo denominador que es 4
así que esto es lo mismo que 5 por 4 20
121 entre cuatro y 21 cuartos es la
fracción impropia que es equivalente a
cinco enteros un cuarto pero ahora vamos
a entender qué es lo que está pasando
que es lo que significa cinco enteros un
cuarto este cinco lo que nos está
diciendo es que tenemos cinco enteros o
cinco cosas vamos a dibujarlas
tenemos 12
y 5 tenemos cinco cosas iguales y este
un cuarto nos está diciendo que tenemos
aparte un cuarto de un entero es decir
tenemos un cuarto
de un entero y voy a dibujar todo el
entero para recalcar que esta parte es
efectivamente un cuarto del entero ahora
vamos a dividir cada una de estas cosas
en cuatro partes entonces tenemos 12
4 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 y por último 1 2 3 4
ahora vamos a contar cuántos pedazos
nuevos tenemos entonces tenemos 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
y 20 es decir toda esta parte de aquí es
lo mismo que 20 cuartos
y pues si lo piensas bien tiene
muchísimo sentido porque veinte cuartos
es lo mismo que cinco el cinco lo
podemos ver como cinco
por 4 entre 4 porque 4 entre 4 es 1 y 5
por 4 es 20 entonces estos 5 enteros son
equivalentes a 20 cuartos pero teníamos
un cuarto más es decir a esto le tenemos
que sumar un cuarto y 20 cuartos más un
cuarto es lo mismo que 21 cuartos
y esta es la manera visual de entender
qué es lo que significa el número mixto
5 enteros 1 cuartos